there is it just me or is this year's  core season carnival gonna soft sir  gonna have to leave no I love  quarterbacks I'm sorry  hey look guys I finally hit the target  I'm sorry I know everyone's rooting for  me don't worry the Colts will help you  win master come right over McFarland  sideline machine sir you're up  nope not yet man where's Eli he said  he'd connect with us here now all that's  scared Oh doh you're polite now remember  I loved you I can't move my feet Eli  where are you I won't leave my coat  pocket a fast rush you're looking for a  pasture any quarterbacks I'm looking for  any non-controversial quarterbacks  anybody on the Steelers well yeah  Shh Don't Tell no siree Bob that maze is  too tricky for me how awful is mess  [Music]  subscribe his channel watch my puzzles  I gotta go